nous sommes le vendredi 6 février 2015
bienvenue pour ce nouveau journal sur
TVfil 78 voici les principaux sujets que
nous allons développer politique avec
l'officialisation de la candidature de
Valérie pcrè pour l'UMP à l'élection
régionale en Île-de-France divorce
prononcé entre les socialistes et ses
anciens alliés de gauche pour les
départementales et puis la démission
surprise du maire de coignère Henry
paayux attrape l'association Emaus
s'installe en face des locaux de pôul
emploi nous reviendrons sur l'action de
la communauté implantée dans la ville
depuis 1988 avec un administrateur
bénévole Jean-Marie Renert invité du
journal et puis nous reviendrons aussi
comme chaque fin de semaine sur ce qu'il
faut retenir depuis lundi lutte contre
la radicalisation dans le département
présentation du parcours du parinis et
un nouveau directeur pour le théâtre
national à montinil bretonne après
l'annonce surprise de sa démiss i après
plus de 30 ans à ce poste Henri paayux
Maire divivers droite de coignère assure
maintenant la promotion de son ouvrage
des séances de dédicace pour celui qui
n'a jamais pratiqué la langue de bois
dans son livre la force de la conviction
un maire et ses combats aux éditions de
l'archipel il raconte sa vie et les
événements marquant qui ont ponctué son
parcours de premier magistrat mais aussi
de conseiller général puis de
vice-président du Conseil général des
Yvelines Henry paayux qui sera la
semaine prochaine à la maison de
voisinage toujours à coignère pour
échanger avec ses administrés et ses
lecteurs il sera aussi l'invité du
prochain 78 politique mardi 18h30 sur
cette antenne et pendant ce temps pour
les régionales l'UMP a officialisé la
candidature de Valérie pcrè en
Île-de-France la députée ancienne
ministre devrait affronter logiquement
en décembre le socialiste Jean-Paul hon
le PS qui doit encore trancher sur une
4e candidature du président sortant
Valérie pcrè s'estime dans un communiqué
que son investiture marque l'unité
retrouvée de l'UMP côté programme elle
dénonce problème de transport de de
logement d'emploi de formation et de
vivre ensemble et puis une autre
information politique Front de gauche et
Europe Écologie les vers main dans la
main pour les prochaines élections
départementales ce sera maintenant dans
un peu plus d'un mois après Rambouillet
lundi une nouvelle candidature commune
vient d'être annoncée aujourd'hui cette
fois sur le canton de Montini le
bretonuguille en cours elle sera portée
par Émilie germain vedren du Parti
communiste et Olivier parjat d'Europe
Écologie une candidature pour proposer
je cite une alternative à la politique
libérale de l'UMP mais aussi du PS
politique toujours Jean-Louis Debray
était ce mardi à Versailles le président
du Conseil constitutionnel invité par
France Culture dans le cadre de
l'émission rencontre du Jeu de Paume
quel est le rôle méconnu de ce Conseil
constitutionnel Jean-Louis Debray a
répondu aux questions de Mélanie poket
et de Michel elmidoro pour
tvfilisque le rôle c'était l'événement
ce mardi à Versailles Jean-Louis Debré
président du Conseil constitutionnel
était invité par France Culture dans
l'émission rencontre du Jeu de Paume un
rendez-vous programmé dans l'enceinte
historique versaillaise l'homme
politique français ministre de
l'Intérieur entre 1995 et
1997 président de l'Assemblée nationale
de 2002 à 2007 est revenu à cette
occasion sur les actions et les
fonctions du Conseil
constitutionnel il est là pour
garantir la Constitution mais surtout le
préambule de la constion 58 qui renvoie
à la déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen de
1789 et qui renvoie aussi au Préambule
de 1946 les droits et les libertés tel
que les républicains tel que les hommes
du 23 juin 1789 l'ont voulu la liberté
d'opinion la laïcité la liberté
d'expression toutes ces libertés qui
sont dans la Déclaration des Droits de
l'Homme les citoyens la liberté
l'association et bien d'autres et bien
la mission du Conseil CONEL et de les
faire
respecter je suis une juridiction
indépendante je juge la loi soit quand
elle est déférée par les parlementaires
le président de la répuique le Premier
ministre ou les présidents desassemblées
soit ce qu'on appelle la question
prioritaire de conalité lorsque des
justiciables et bien contestent un
article de loi d'une loi ils peuvent
dans certaines conditions nous
saisir nous avons annuler une loi de
1831 ou 38 qui était l'hospitalisation
sans consentement et qui avait cette loi
qui avait fait que Camille Claudel l'ami
de Rodin avait été hospitalisé pendant
30 ans nous avons annulé les tribunaux
maritimes qui dataient de Colbert parce
que la composition du tribunal il y
avait des gens qui n'étaient pas des
juges
fonctionn pendant des sièclle mais
chaque fois nous
revisitons nous pouvons pas nous saisir
mais à la demande de justiciable ou de
représentants de de l'État ou de la
nation nous revisitons nos droits et nos
libertés et n nous regardons si ils ont
été
respectés écoutez c'est une toute petite
équipe puisque le Conseil constitionnel
c'est en tout de de de de du personnel
d'entretien au président 60 personnes
quand je suis arrivé le Conseil rendait
16 décisions par an nous en rendons
250 avec
euh euh
9 8 membres 9 membres 9 nef avec moi qui
sont là et qui tous les jours jugent les
recours qui sont déposés par nos
concitoyens d'une durée de 9 ans le
mandat de Jean-Louis Debray à la tête du
Conseil constitutionnel s'achève en
2016 on en viient aux annonces du préfet
des ivelines concernant la lutte contre
la radicalisation et le djihadisme
Herard Corbin de manjouan cette campagne
gouvernementale cette semaine les
détails avec michelmido et William
l les ivines sont particulièrement
touché par le djihadisme zone
d'attention pour les forces de l'ordre
50 ans Livine et la vallée la Scine au
total une centaine de signalements ont
été enregistrés depuis mai 2014 dans le
département les individus auraient en
moyenne entre 15 et 30 ans le phénomène
concernerait aussi bien les garçons que
les filles on va pas donner de chiffr
parce que ça n'a pas d'importance mais
ulines comme tout département urbains et
de la région- de France sont
naturellement touchés dans dans tout son
espace par par cette situation et et
quand je vous disais sensignalement ils
sont répartis sur toutes l'air urbaine
pour lutter contre le djihadisme dans
les ivlines le département s'associe à
la campagne nationale contre le
terrorisme un numéro vert a été mis en
place une brochure explicatif sur les
signaux de radicalisation est également
téléchargeable sur le site internet de
la préfecture ObjC
prévenir la radicalisation et offrir une
assistance aux familles dans la
difficulté ce sont des indices
concordants qui font que on
va on va essayer de de constater cette
radicalité c'est DESS simple alors bien
sûr les tenues vestimentaire mais pas
seulement c'est peut être aussi le fait
de de de ne plus regarder la télévision
de ne plus écouter de la musique de
d'être très porté sur les réseaux
sociaux sur des sites très très
spécifiques ça peut être aussi
d'abandonner le sport ça peut tout un
ensemble encore une fois de de d'indices
qui permettent de dire il se passe
quelque chose une fois le signalement
effectué des structures nationales et
départementales s'occupent des individus
considérés comme radicaux au cas par cas
nous avons mis en place comme je pense
dans l'ensemble des départements
concernés d'avoir une cellule de suivi
extrêmement restreinte ou où tous les
cas sont évoqués et une cellule
d'évaluation nationale avec l'ensemble
des partenaires où nous p pouvons là
essayer de trouver quel est
l'organisme l'institution l'association
qui est le mieux à même de prendre en
compte la situation une fois que nous
avons pu l'évaluer savoir si c'était un
vrai casadre radicalisation ou bien
simplement un moment difficile d'un
adolescent le djihadisme dans les iines
fait cette semaines les gros titres de
l'actualité Moussa Koulibali l'agresseur
présumé de trois polici anis mardi
dernier habité le quartier du valfouré
monte la
jolie l'invité de cette édition à
présent Jean-Marie Reard bonjour
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes
administrateur bénévoolle d'emus à
trrappe votre actualité c'est
l'ouverture de nouveaux locaux dans la
commune on vous trouverz jusqu'à présent
avenue de l'armée Leclerc l'association
emus va s'installer maintenant au 201
avenu des boulot c'est en face du Pôle
Emploi attrape pourquoi ce déménagement
tout simplement oui d'abord je voudrais
vous dire que je me présente au nom de
l'ensemble de la communauté c'est
préalable deuxièmement le déménagement
au sens propre du mot est terminé nous
sommes installés maintenant au 20 avenue
des boulot à trappe si vous ne savez pas
c'est l'avenue des boulau donne sur la
route de trappe et euh
elle est comment dirait elle se situe
devant notre communauté se situe devant
pourô l'emploi voilà pour bien le situer
pour pour vous trouver alors qu'est-ce
qui a motivé ce déménagement alors
motivé il y a des raisons internes il y
a des raisons externes h h d' on a été
poussé l'installation est terminée on a
été poussé à ce déménagement bah vous
êtes pas sans savoir de fait
le l'enfouissement de l'iren 12 banal m
oui de deuxièmement le réaménagement du
plateau urbain du centre-ville comme
nous étions dans le centreeville nous
avons été automatiquement impactés dans
ce cette ce aménagement voà c'est raison
c'est une des premières raisons
effectivement pour pouvoir permettre
l'aménagement de la ville des nouveaux
loc et alors sur RA les locaux étaient
de moins en moins adaptés à notre à nos
objectifs et de ce fait nous étions ils
étaient un salubre et il nous a fallu
trouver autre chose ça va nous permettre
de parler de vos objectifs parce que la
communauté us a été créée en 1988 à
trrape aujourd'hui combien de personnes
sont accueillies quel travail est mené
là-bas je voudrais reprendre quand même
ce été dit pourquoi la nouvelle le 201
ben parce que et en même temps ça vous
parlera des inadaptations parce que un
on a beaucoup plus d'espace donc ça
c'est important deuxièmement on a des
activités regroupées et troisièmement
euh on a une meilleure accessibilité et
pour les gens de trappe et pour les gens
de de l'agglomération car on vise
l'agglomération alors vous m'excuseerez
j'en viens aux objectifs parce qu'on
vaêtre sinon pris par le temps sur cet
entretien si on va un petit peu tout
aborder malheureusement qu'est-ce que
aujourd'hui quel est le travail pardon
qui est qui est mené combien de
personnes sont sont accueillies
accompagné par cette communauté maisus
alors actuellement nous avons deux
objectifs vous n posz Le problèm des
objectifs le premier problème c'est
le dans la période de c'est d'accueillir
la clientèle et de trappe et de la gllo
c'est notre premier objectif le deuxième
c'est quand la situation sera stabilit
stabiliser quand on sera sorti de la
période actuelle de remise en route
c'est l'accueil des compagnons vous
devinez que entre le passé et le présent
il nous a fallu nous priver de des
compagnons que nous pouvions avoir alors
ça nous permet de recituer aussi pour
les personnes qui ne connaissent pas le
mode de fonctionnement desmaus ces
compagnons ce sont des personnes qui
travaillent pour il y a deux deux je
veux dire une terminologie qu' qu'on a
le compagnon et celui qui est accueilli
par la
communauté il
estébergé git et couvert en fonction de
soi il donne son sa part il participe
aux travaux aux activités de la
communauté et en même temps doit
répondre aux impératifs de la vie
collective on regarde la situation
actuelle un peu la popérisation de la
société je n'oublierai pas la deuxième
élément c'est les bénévoles dans la
phase actuelle les bénévoles ont joué un
rôle capital par la volonté de maintenir
la présence parce que vous devinez que
la décision de déménager n'a pas été
facile et il y a fallu une volonté de
ceci de euh vouloir maintenir la
communauté dans la continuité de la
pensée de l'abé pierre justement cette
pensée de laabé piierre le mode de
fonctionnement aujourd'hui face à une
popérisation de plus en plus grande de
la population des nouveaux modes aussi
de de de de popérisation les nouvelles
personnes qui sont qui sont concernées
est-ce que tout ça est un peu remis en
cause est-ce qu'aujourd'hui le mode de
fonctionnement des Maus est encore
adapté je diraai que le mode de
fonctionnement demeure tel qu'il est
mais c'est vrai qu'on a des adaptations
très considérable à faire du fait d'une
mutation de ceux qui qui frappent à nos
portes h c'est vraiment une mutation
considérable avant on avait le SDF que
l'on que l'on rencontrait maintenant
sont des jeunes émigrés qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de de vie en société euh mais
maintenant c'est comme je vous ai dit
l'objectif là on n pas à perdre du temps
l'objectif c'est la remise en route de
l'appareil pour pouvoir accueillir des
gens répondant à nos critères et cette
mise en route justement vous êtes fixé
ben ça y
est demain s'ouvre de 10h à 18 17h30
s'ouvre le nos magasins tous les mardis
tous les mercredis veuxje dire de euh
14h à 17h30 les mercredis et les samedis
de 10h en Contin continu jusqu'à 17h30
voilà les horaires sont donnés et juste
une dernière question vous parliez de
cette évolution et d'un nouveau public à
accueillir et des modes de
fonctionnement réinventé comment vous y
faites face justement vous dites c'est
une réflexion qui se met en cours pour
accueillir les les nouvelles populations
c'est pas seulement une réflexion c'est
une comment on y fait face d'abord il
nous faut trouver euh pour l'aspect
accueil c'est notre vocation on y
restera fidèle maintenant pour
l'hébergement nous aurons nous aurons
des problèmes à régler et pourquoi pas
c'est une pensée qu'on a ne pas chercher
un partenariat avec la Ville pour que la
ville se chargeant de l'hébergement euh
et nous nous chgeons de l'encadrement de
l'activité et de l'accueil de ses
compagnons en tout cas emus a donc
ouvert ses porte le déménagement c'est
bon vous nous l'avez dit naturellement
ce sera doravant au 20 avenu des boulot
toujours àrape en face du Pôle emploi
pour le situé précisément merci à vous
nous reprenons le cours du journal avec
les chiffres de la sécurité routière sur
l'année 2014 qui ont été dévoilé le
nombre de morts sur les routes de
département est plutôt stable par
rapport à 2013 47 personnes ont trouvé
la mort sur les routes un reportage de
William l et de Michel dem
d'euros les chiffres viennent de tomber
47 personnes ont perdu la vie l'année
dernière sur les routes du département
autant qu'en 2013 le nombre d'accidents
est également stable avec 946
accrochages contre 947 l'année dernière
dans le rétroviseur de la police
ivinoise les deux roues 25 % des
accidents mortels des ivines concernent
des motards il faut qu'on continue à
travailler avec les motards pour qu'il
respecte mieux les limitations de
vitesse les ces de la route je reste per
dire que le comportement doit être mieux
mieux calibré et je et pour ma part je
continuerai à à demander à ce que les
remontées de fil trop rapide soit soi
verbalisé par les forces de police parce
que je trouve que ça donne un
comportement beaucoup trop libertaire et
ça donne une route dangereuse et un
sentiment de de trop grande liberté sur
la route pour réduire le nombre de morts
sur les routes du département les forces
de l'ordre veulent augmenter les
contrôles de vitesse avec avec des
radars mobiles dans les secteurs urbains
des tests salivaires pour lutter contre
la prise de stupéfiance sur la route
sont également développés en 2015 une
très très forte hausse délis routiers
nous avons constaté plus plus 40 % de
délis routiers l'année dernière ce qui
est énorme nous avons plus 20 % de délit
de grande vitesse nous avons plus de 40
% de de délit d'alcoolémi délictuel y
compris presque plus de 50 % de conduit
sous stupéfiant toutes les semaines je
constate des grands c'est que cetteette
vitesse écoutez la semaine dernière
c'était 160 km/h au milieu d'un village
limité à 50 km/h mais si quelqu'un
traverse il ne peut pas s'arrêterin et
s'il essaie d'éviter la personne le
motard va tomber c'est clair donc là
c'est vraiment ce sont pas des
comportement citoyen et c'est là aussi
qu'il faut qu'il nous faut intervenir
cette année cinq personnes ont déjà
perdu la vie sur les routes du
département dans deux accidents mortels
en zone rural on a tous une bonne raison
de rester vivant association prévention
routière
la mobilisation dans l'éducation aez peu
suivi en début de semaine mais malgré
tout plusieurs écoles étaient fermées
mardi en raison d'un mouvement de grève
lancé principalement par le syndicat FSU
les raisons d'une colère d'une partie de
la profession avec Mélanie
poquet des cours de récréation désertes
pas un bruit autour des établissements
une scène commune dans des écoles
cinquantinoises ce mardi les professeurs
grvistes ont plusieurs
revendications c'est la mise en place
des nouveaux rythmes
scolaires qui s'est faite d'une façon
assez anarchique qui a désorganisé
complètement les écoles à titre purement
indicatif il y a une circonscription des
Yvelines où il y a 38 zoraires
différents donc il est évident qu'après
ça impacte
forcément les situations de remplacement
de complément de service et cetera je
vais donner un autre exemple qui est
celui des remplacements nous sommes ici
à trappe depuis la rentrée de de janvier
c'est entre 14 à 20 professeurs qui ne
sont pas remplacés chaque jour sur les
écoles de trappe donc effectivement ce
sont des
désorganisations c'est une continuité de
l'enseignement qui ne peut pas être
assuré c'est des gros problèmes puisque
une partie des enfants sont répartis
d'autres sont enenvoyés donc une
surcharge de de d'élèves dans les
classes il faut savoir que un jeune
professeur des écoles commence à 117 %
du SMIC que cette année alors je vais
passer sur les sur les péripétieses mais
il faut savoir que les jeunes
professeurs des écoles qui commencent
cette année sont moins bien payés que
ceux qui ont commencé l'année dernière
et quant à la grille générale des des
enseignants elle est très en dessa de la
moyenne de l'OCDE d'ailleurs ça se
traduit dans les difficultés qu'il y a à
recruter l'année dernière pour la
première fois le concours de professeurs
des écoles n'a pas fait le
plein les jeunes professeurs des écoles
stagiaires servent de moyen
d'enseignement ils doivent assurer un
demi-service ce ne sont pas des bonnes
conditions de de comment dirais-je de de
formation initiale l'année dernière ils
assuraient une journée par semaine
maintenant c'est 2 jours une semaine 2
jours et demi l'autre semaine sachant
que dans le même temps ils doivent
valider un Master 2 donc ils sont
submergés de travail l'université a
beaucoup de mal à organiser des horaires
réguliers pour eux ce sont ce n'est
absolument pas des conditions
satisfaisantes de de formation initiale
le SNUI P FSU Eveline annonce 15 à 20 %
d'enseignants grvistes pour le rectorat
ils étaient près de 12 % dans le premier
degré et les
collèges autre contestation cette
semaine celle des médecins projet de loi
santé mais aussi absence de
revalorisation tarifaire figure parmi
leur Grif les grèves se multiplient
depuis le mois de décembre les cabin
était une nouvelle fois fermée jeudi
dernier nous en avons parlé en plateau
avec Bernadette Zambon elle est
vice-présidente du Syndicat national des
jeunes médecins généraliste
écoutez vous représenteer le syndicat
des jeunes médecins est-ce qu'il y a des
revendications spécifiques aussi autour
de cette réforme santé de cette loi
santé qui est en préparation qui sont
porté par votre syndicat oui ce qu'on
aimerait aussi c'est une revalorisation
du statut de l'interne en M général et
une revalorisation de de la formation
pendant l'internat et puis ensuite la
formation continue
professionnel avec notamment plus de
moyens pour l'enseignement pour la
recherche aujourd'hui la médecine
générale est une spécialité à
partentière mais la recherche clinique
et un peu le parent pauvre par rapport
aux autres spécialités avec peu de de
dotation financièrees dans ce sens-là et
et le statut des internes est vraiment
précaire avec des des allégations qui
avaient été faites par la Commission
européenne sur le temps de travail des
internes qui ont pas été du tout
reprises par le gouvernement et aucune
avané n'était fait dans ce
sens-là et puis par rapport à à à la
formation continue ce qu'on aimerait
aussi c'est une possibilité d'avoir 10
journées par an de de financement pour
faire une formation continue en tant que
généraliste donc il a toute une partie
formation aussi qu'importante pour nous
autre invité cette semaine sur le
plateau du journal Lionel meta c'est le
nouveau directeur de la scène nationale
des Yvelines il vient de prendre ses
fonctions il ne manque pas de projet
extrait d'un entretien à retrouver comme
comme les autres d'ailleurs en
intégralité grâce au replay sur notre
site internet mais on va dire qu'il y a
des choses qui vont se poursuivre ou ou
se renforcer et d'autres choses qui vont
être un tout petit peu nouvelles alors
dans les choses qui vont se poursuivre
il y a un travail absolument remarquable
qui a été mené par l'équipe de Jacques
Pornon et par Marie Didier qui a assuré
administratrice du lieu qui a assuré
l'intérim et je tiens également à lui
rendre hommage ce soirn l'ancien
directeur JAC Pornon ancien directeur de
la scène nationale pendant 10 ans un
travail remarquable qui a été fait
autour de l'art lyrique notamment pas
que un travail de démocratisation
culturelle donc ce travaill là autour de
l' lyrique va se poursuivre la question
de la pluridisciplinarité qui est au
cœur du projet de cette scène nationale
qui a un cahier des charges la
pluridisciplinarité sera renforcée et
dans les directions de programmation de
la saison prochaine elle est déjà déjà
renforcée ça c'est des choses qui vont
se poursuivre ensuite il va y avoir des
nouveautés en effet dans les nouveautés
je citerai je citerai deux choses la la
question des partenair partariat vous en
parliez elle est essentielle et pour moi
elle est au cœur du projet les
partenariats ils vont se renforcer on
parle de partenariats locaux au sein de
la casquie avec des des partenaires
naturels que sont les autres théâtres
que peut être le musée que peut être le
réseau de médiathèque il y a des
partenariats qui peuvent se développer
au-delà de la casquie et puis des
partenariats encore au-delà enfin
au-delà de la casquie au-delà du
département et et dans la région au-delà
de la région il est important de
souligner que c'est une scène nationale
donc fortement soutenue par euh la
communauté d'agglomération de 50 an en
Yveline par le département mais
également par l'État avec des missions
très claires à savoir un ancrage local
d'une part mais également une mission de
rayonnement au-delà de la Communauté
d'agglomération du sport maintenant la
Course au Soleil départ le 8 mars pour
quelquesuns des meilleurs coureurs du
monde cela débutera à mortp dans les
ivlines le tracé vient tout juste d'être
dévoilé le tracé du Paris Nice 2015 a
été dévoilé par amoris Sport
Organisation cela devient une habitude
pour la 6e année consécutive les
premiers coups de de cette 73e
édition seront donnés depuis le
département des yvelin morpa a été
sélectionné pour accueillir le prologue
le 8 mars prochain le peloton sélancera
également de saint-rémis les chouruses
pour la première étape programmée le
lendemain on est toujours très heureux
non seulement de partir des ivelines euh
pour la compétition sportive mais aussi
parce qu'il y a autour de la compétition
un tas euh d'événements je pense au
villages qui s installés aux randonnées
qui sont faites c'est un département
cyclable hein quand on dit euh tout sa
vélo dans les ivelines ça veut vraiment
dire quelque chose on voit de plus en
plus de cyclos le weekend ou en semaine
profiter des côtes profiter du terrain
c'est vrai qu'on est tout près de Paris
et qu'en même temps on est aussi à la
campagne donc pour les les gens à
bicyclette comme pour les champions à
vélo c'est un département euh quasiment
idéal pour la pratique du cyclisme le
prologue de morpa long de 6 km 700 est
très technique des écarts entre les
concurrents sont à prévoir dès ce contre
la montre le départ euh ne sera pas au
même endroit que l'arrivée donc ça sera
vraiment deux endroits distins distincts
avec 1 km de différence entre entre ces
deux points là mais c'est un parcours en
campagne carrément en campagne la
première partie c'est une partie boisée
et ensuite un retour vers mon repas vers
une difficulté on va dire que c'est la
côte du donjon je vais l'appeler comme
ça parce qu'on passe pas loin du donjon
et avec D rolances pour aller chercher
l'arrivée donc boulevard Michel misery
donc c'est pas un parcours tout plat
c'est pas des grandes routes c'est
vraiment assez technique et on pourrait
avoir des surprises après cette étape
très prisé par par les cyclistes
amateurs les routes sinueuses de
Saint-Rémi les chevreuses ont été
remises au programme de ce Parisis 2015
c'est vrai qu'on a fait une arrivée
d'étape en 2012 à Saint-Rémi les
chevreuses du contre la montre là on va
on va y repartir mais Saint-Rémi c'est
dans la vallé de Chevreuse on est bien
abrité du vent et après 3 km il y a une
difficulté c'est la seule difficulté
elle est pas très dure mais c'est seule
difficulté qui compte pour le classement
du meilleur grimpeur donc ce qui veut
dire qu' l'arrivée bien il y aura un
maillot de de distribuer donc je pense
que ça va partir très vite le décor est
désormais planté les stars du cyclisme
Jean-Christophe perra Thomas volore
Bradley Wiggin sont encore richiport
doivent maintenant écrire le scénario de
cette course du soleil premier chapitre
le 8 mars prochain à
morpa c'est la fin du journal
rendez-vous lundi aux horaires
habituelle pour une nouvelle édition
pour faire un point complet très bon
weekend